was geht ab jetzt willkommen bei wollen
video ja leider hatte ich diese woche
nicht ganz so viel zeit für euch ein
video zu drehen da ich sehr viel stress
mit der schule klausuren unsere kenntnis
er bestimmt auf jeden fall will ich
natürlich dennoch was cool ist euch raus
halt und da ich eh letztens mit meiner
freundin einkaufen war beziehungsweise
schoppen wein wieder fällt keiner ob ich
das was sagt auf jeden fall habe ich an
diesem tag so viel eingekauft erschöpft
wie noch nie in meinem leben zuvor und
ich hab die ganze sache jetzt hier
liegen ich würde mal gerne so ein
shopping mall oder wie das heißt man
keine ahnung wie das ankommt werden wir
dann sehen auf jeden fall wenn ihr das
mal öfter sehen wollen oder wenn solche
fälle gibt einfach ein daumen nach oben
und ich wünsche euch dann natürlich ganz
viel spaß so leute dann würde ich mal
sagen ich nehme es einfach mal
diese tüte hier und zwar ist mir
irgendwann aufgefallen dass sie gar
keine jogginghose map und wirklich mal
eine neue brauch und ich glaube ist er
noch in der h & m
die habe ich von h&m das ist eine graue
jogginghose und ich weiß gar nicht mehr
wie teuer die wahl glaubt 20 euro oder
so keine ahnung
ihr kennt ja schon diese typischen haut
dringen dass auf jeden fall so eine so
als nächstes nehmen einfach mal die
t-shirts und zwar ist das ein loblied
auf das habe ich weiß nicht ob ihr den
laden kennen den gibt sich überall oder
ich weiß nicht ob sie die wahl gibt auf
jeden fall heißt der laden snipes keine
ahnung ob ich auf jeden fall dieses t
shirt her und dann auch noch und denkt
ja genau und dann auch noch das t-shirt
was sie gerade up ist mir gerade
eingefallen
moment mal dieses t shirt was ihr getan
habt habe ich new yorker oder so ist ja
dann kennt ihr bestimmt und von new york
habe ich auch noch dieses t shirt moment
das ich habe glaube ich beide zusammen
für 20 euro bekommen bei irgendwann
angebot genauso wie bei swype star ich
halt dieses top t shirt hat und dann
noch so ein schwarzes ich habe das
irgendwie gerade schon nicht also schon
mal anders
also ich hab es nicht gefunden da steht
so 99 problems drauf oder irgendwie so
auf jeden fall kann ich euch einfach mal
ein foto ein bin oder so vielleicht habt
ihr es ja schon oft gesehen
auf jeden fall kommen wir dann zunächst
gesagt ich gehe mit einem architekten
auch von hartem und zwar braucht dich
unbedingt eine hose dass dies jetzt
nicht eine für 20 euro ich habe sonst
möglich um 12 23 euro kostet behaupten
sondern soll ein 40 euro ich hoffe ihr
40 euro kostet dienst ist das glaube ich
schon
ich kenne dich mit diese ganze
shopbereich großmärkte ja vielleicht ja
unter anderem hier nochmal diese beiden
großen einmal hier war künstlich hat nur
20 euro kostet aber gefällt mir mega und
die hatte ich auch schon einmal an
und ansonsten noch diese hose hier jetzt
glaube ich 30 euro kostet hoffmann h & m
beides und new york und jetzt liegen
hier die ganze nacht und dann habe ich
mir einfach noch mal gedacht weil ich
diese teile total cool finde majoran ich
glaube den gibt es nur in bielefeld
wie ist er im auge so oder so und zwar
ist das habe ich mir gedacht ja nimmst
jetzt den wo das weiß ist unter nimmst
du das
oranges und meine freundin hat gesagt
ich soll das nehmen dann habe ich mir
den genommen er hat glaube ich 80 euro
gekostet war ein bisschen teurer aber
musste halt auch mal sein weil ich den
cool finden und dann haben wir hier noch
sondern ganz normal pullover auch von
sap von new yorker glaub ich war das ein
pullover
ja das ist einfach so da sind ja so
zipfel dran und das geht ein bisschen
weiter hoch hier für den winter halt und
ja ganz zum schluss dann ebenfalls von
hmmm jetzt wiederum also separat von new
yorker und der kompliziert den habe ich
hier schon den finde ich auch mega cool
das ist so eine polin und ja der ist
auch ziemlich warm und er sieht auch
mega cool aussieht kann ja einfach mal
anziehen
ja also das sieht dann so aus ich finde
den mega cool wir können ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben werden findet auf
jeden fall war das jetzt so ziemlich
alle sachen ich überlege noch mal kurz
ja eigentlich müsste das jetzt alles
gewesen sein ich kann mich noch mal
diesen polizei gegen mich haben schon
ziemlich viele gefragt wo es den ägypten
habe ich zum geburtstag bekommen von
meiner freundin und ich weiß nicht ich
kann sie mal fragen und dann schreibe
ich den link dazu einfach mal und mini
infobox und ansonsten war das so alles
jetzt ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie
ich schon gesagt habe
gebt einfach noch nach oben wenn ihr
davon noch mit zweite ausgabe sehen
wollen oder immer wenn ich einkaufen
gehe dass ihr euch das zeige oder so wir
auf jeden fall mehr cool würde mich
freuen dass auch bisschen spaß macht
unter ansonsten check ins und co ist
hier eingeblendet in der video
beschreibung twitter und so ansonsten
geht sie auf der rechten seite weiter
mit meinem letzten video das waren no
gos bei mädchen der zweite teil hier auf
der linken seite lasst euch überraschen
chips auch auf jeden fall weiß man das
wirklich wollen wir nämlich abonniert
und wir sehen uns dann nächste woche
wieder hat ein